[Music]
i'm the strong one i'm not nervous i'm
as tough as the crust of the earth is
okay
i move mountains i move churches can i
glow cause i know what my worth is of
course i mean hey where are you going i
don't ask how hard the work is gotta
rough and destructed the surface
diamonds and platinum i finally flatten
them i take what i'm handed i'll break
what's demanded but under the surface i
feel berserk as a tight rope walker in a
three-ring circus under the surface was
hercules ever like yo
under the surface
i'm pretty sure i'm worthless if i can
be of
[Music]
[Music]
till you just go
[Music]
many years ago
this scandal blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita came to life with
magic
la casita
[Music]
in time every member of our family
cecilia
was given their own magical gift
uh-huh uh-huh i understand you
i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like
perfect
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with an alle
pacon queso
casita what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
i'm losing my gift
[Music]
the fate of the family
[Music]
let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
[Music]
but at least i'll have a friend nope you
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
you